The Origin of the Republican Party
Pro environmental legislation, peace, universal
health care and progressive policies (including
raising taxes)- your granddaddy wouldn't recognize
the GOP of today.
So how did the Republic Party get its start
and evolve to its modern state?
By the mid-19th century, the fabric of the
United States was being torn apart by slavery.
The famous 1820 agreement, the Missouri Compromise,
which had prohibited the spread of slavery
in much of the former Louisiana Territory,
was repealed in 1854.
Northern anti-slavery activists, including
luminaries Salmon Chase, Charles Sumner and
Horace Greeley, came together to form an anti-slavery
party.
Greeley, in a June 1854 New York Times editorial,
christened the party: “We should not care
much whether those thus united [against slavery]
were designated "Whig," "Free Democrat" or
something else; though we think some simple
name like Republican would more fitly designate
those who had united to restore the Union
to its true mission of champion and promulgator
of Liberty rather than propagandist of slavery."A
meeting was held on June 6, 1854 "Under the
Oaks" near Jackson, Michigan in which 10,000
people attended.
Shortly thereafter, the newly formed Republican
party gained control of Michigan, and made
significant inroads elsewhere.
As such, by 1855, the Republicans controlled
the U.S. House of Representatives.
At its national convention on June 17, 1856,
John C. Fremont was the first nominee to represent
the party in the race for President of the
United States; the famous slogan for his unsuccessful
bid was: "Free Press, Free Soil, Free Men,
Fremont and Victory."
The Party of Lincoln The Republican Party
saw its first President in the form of Abraham
Lincoln who won the election of 1860 and became
the 16th President of the United States on
March 4, 1861.
On April 12, 1861, Confederate forces fired
on Fort Sumter and the United States Civil
War officially began.
On January 1, 1863, Lincoln issued the Emancipation
Proclamation that stated: "that all persons
held as slaves" in the Confederacy "are, and
henceforward shall be free."
Lincoln died on April 14, 1865, but the Republican
Party carried on the civil rights crusade.
With Reconstruction, the 13th (outlawing slavery),
14th (guaranteeing civil rights) and 15th
(right to vote) Amendments to the Constitution
were passed, as well as the Civil Rights Act
of 1866.
These protected newly freed slaves and others
alike to vote, own land, find work, use public
accommodations and hold public office.
The Party of Roosevelt (the other Roosevelt)Ascending
to become the 26th President of the United
States at the death of William McKinley on
September 6, 1901, Theodore Roosevelt is remembered
not only for his Rough Riders and tough talk
("Speak Softly and Carry a Big Stick"), but
his commitment to the environment and his
fellow man.
Teddy broke the power of the trusts (powerful
monopolies), won a Nobel Peace Prize for helping
to end the Russo-Japanese War and created
numerous national parks, forest reserves and
national monuments.
Crater Lake, Devil's Tower and large areas
of the Grand
Canyon are only three noteworthy examples
of the dozens of wild places he protected.
During his tenure, U.S. forests reserves quadrupled
from 43 million to 194 million acres.
The Party of Eisenhower The 34th President
of the United States, Republican Dwight D.
Eisenhower swept into office with a policy
of "Modern Republicanism."
A war hero, he was the Supreme Commander of
allied forces during the successful D-Day
invasion on June 6, 1944.
Taking office in 1953 during the Cold War,
Eisenhower was committed to peace, and counted
signing the armistice that ended the Korean
Conflict among his accomplishments.
Also committed to civil rights, he ordered
U.S. troops to support integration of the
schools in Little Rock, and is quoted as saying:
"there must be no second class citizens in
this country."
In his Farewell Presidential Address to the
nation, Eisenhower warned us to be vigilant
against the undue influence of the defense
industry on government: “A vital element
in keeping the peace is our military establishment.
Our arms must be might, ready for instant
action, so that no potential aggressor may
be tempted to risk his own destruction . . . . But
now we can no longer risk emergency improvisation
of national defense; we have been compelled
to create a permanent armaments industry of
vast proportions . . . . This conjunction
of an immense military establishment and a
large arms industry is new in the American
experience . . . . Yet we must not fail to
comprehend its grave implications . . . . In
the councils of government, we must guard
against the acquisition of unwarranted influence,
whether sought or unsought, by the military-industrial
complex.
The potential for the disastrous rise of misplaced
power exists and will persist.”The Party
of NixonSetting aside any high crimes and
misdemeanors, the 37th President of the United
States Richard M. Nixon had some significant
accomplishments during his five years in office.
He was the first American president to visit
the People's Republic of China in February
1972, and his talks with Soviet General Secretary
Leonid Brezhnev led to the Strategic Arms
Limitation Treaty (a nuclear limitation pact).
Domestically, Nixon established the Environmental
Protection Agency (EPA) in 1970.
Later,when he signed the Clean Air Act on
December 31, 1970, he opined, "I think that
1970 will be known as the year of the beginning,
in which we really began to move on the problems
of clear air and clean water and open spaces
for the future generations of America."
Also of note, in 1971, Nixon, imposed price
controls and ended the gold standard for the
dollar.
In September of that year, he abolished the
military draft.
But perhaps the most surprising thing about
his presidency was his idea for a "Comprehensive
Health Insurance Plan."
Proposed to Congress on February 6, 1974,
Nixon advocated a universal
health care system that is remarkably similar
to the Affordable Care Act (a.k.a. Obamacare)
of 2010.
The Party of ReganOur 40th President of the
United States Ronald Reagan was not afraid
to tax and spend when the country needed it.
In 1983, he agreed to a $165 billion bailout
of an ailing Social Security program.
He also created the Department of Veterans
Affairs on March 15, 1989, a much-needed agency
that added more than 60,000 people to the
federal payroll.
More shockingly, however, he is credited with
raising taxes 11 times.
As noted historian Douglas Brinkly told NPR:
"Ronald Reagan was never afraid to raise taxes.
. . . He knew that it was necessary at times."